my question is I'm starting with three
businesses how to promote each one of
them in every way the biggest thing is
focus I would look at this on a
long-term vision for what does Sergio
want to create where do we want to go
what is our life plan right and then for
making money think of these in steps so
instead of all three at the same time
which one do you want to do first and it
might be just which one can pay you more
first maybe the wedding business pays
you first and faster and it's maybe not
your deepest passion but it gets you
paid so that you can focus on the other
things the challenge that a lot of
entrepreneurs have is we have so many
great ideas and so many things that we
could do and then we start all of them
and then nothing ends up happening
because we've applied a little bit of
effort across three different ideas
instead of if you said hey I have a
focused a lot of my effort on one I
might be able to have some serious
success so instead of saying only do one
idea I'm saying just start with one idea
and make that thing work and then the
next one and then the next one and then
the next one can happen like if Peter
makes these animation videos if he also
wanted to make long-form YouTube videos
and he wanted to open up a podcast space
for people to rent to come and do
podcasts from from his studio and all
these other ideas that are related it's
cool but trying to do all of them
together would mean he does nothing
so what's the order you know pick the
business that you think can start
generating money for you
and then focusing on that one before
going to the next uh Sandra mentioned
aweber yeah so for the email question we
use aweber to send out emails most of
them are the same whether it's aweber or
MailChimp or the other programs but from
from all of these the easiest one to
think about is at the beginning of a
business instead of thinking business to
Consumer think business to business so
Step One is figure out which of these
three businesses is the one that you're
going to start with the focus energy on
and start making money with
the next becomes inside of that that one
business what's the easiest way to go
business to business instead of business
to consumer
so if I look at Peter's business again
an example if he's selling
animation videos to individuals
could he sell some sure could he sell
like a happy birthday video to somebody
I'm sure but the problem is it's really
hard to get scale it's really hard to
get big you need to be really well known
or spend a lot on marketing to get a lot
of individuals to know you and it's
mostly these one-off sales somebody who
buys a happy Birthday animation video
they're only going to buy one happy
Birthday animation video where if he
sold the businesses which ultimately is
you know what he's basically trying to
do
they won't just buy one video they'll
buy three videos every week from him to
create
so that one client generates a lot more
money for a lot less effort than trying
to go off and find all these new clients
who pay a little bit of money so in your
first example virtual courses for
electro engineering to students and
professionals if that's the model you
pick we don't want to go and try to sell
students and professionals one-on-one
we need to figure out who are the
businesses
or the organizations that if they knew
who you were they could take you to a
thousand professionals or a thousand
students
so we want a few relationships that lead
to a lot of sales instead of a lot of
relationships that lead to a little and
few sales because the marketing the
promotion becomes really really hard as
you build and get bigger and have a
brand and have an audience all of those
things become easier
but this is where a lot of people end up
stopping their businesses because they
they have a great idea but they're just
not making any money doing it
so what's the fastest way to do it's
typically through a business
relationship so Step One is figure out
where to focus
which of these three businesses we're
going to focus on and then step two from
that business
how do we make it a business to business
relationship
instead of trying to sell directly to
the consumer because then it allows us
to be able to grow a lot faster and have
more sustained Revenue ongoing
when we posting something on IG then I I
saw some competitors they come to
comment to my post is it a good way for
us
to go to comment to other competitor
posts as well it's probably where I
wouldn't spend too much time
you know like I think that the value of
the comments are decreasing
um if there's someone who you really
want to try to build a relationship with
and you know that they are responding to
comments then maybe but if I had to pick
between
it's not that it's a bad idea it's just
is it the best use of your time versus
other things I would rather you spend if
I'm you I'd rather spend time making
more content and specifically paying
attention to
the retention curves of your videos
both on YouTube and on Instagram to see
where are people falling off on the
videos to just get
to get better
to make better content because that you
know the Whiteboard animation videos
some of them super well and not just
like you but just in general like
whiteboard animation
is great because you
you're taking you're taking words and
making them into a picture and a story
which makes it easier for people to
understand and you're taking like your
favorite 40 seconds or minute or 15
whatever however long and and cutting it
up
uh
so it's figuring out what does the next
level in whiteboard videos look like so
that you become the guy that everybody
wants to go to to help them make videos
are you doing it yourself or you have a
team helping you
I do it myself
cool and it's a great start I like it
and so you're picking uh you're picking
quotes that you like hopefully you know
and when you're pulling up my stuff
hopefully you like you like the things
that uh that I'm saying but now it's
figuring out and and the retention Curve
will tell you
which ones are holding attention and
which ones are not and is it the music
that you add in is it a certain
animation style is it putting text on
the screen like all of those things
become super important because if you
can really crack that
then it becomes a service that you can
really easily sell to other people I'm
super excited like when you started
doing it it's like this is great and and
that is it's definitely a business
you definitely have a business
opportunity there the biggest thing I
would look at is I don't know that your
whiteboard videos look different enough
from other people's whiteboard videos
yet
and so it's figuring out how to master
there with the attention curve
especially in an Instagram environment
or like the the short form that you're
doing
you know YouTube would say 70 at one
minute like Instagram and YouTube shorts
everything is so much even it's like
fast like one minute the video is
already over right it says like how do
you master the first 10 seconds the
first three seconds that people want to
watch it and playing around with those
things because if you can
if you can prove that your method Works
whether it's sound effects whether it's
the right uh picture or image or text or
animation or whatever it is to hook
attention
it's the kind of thing that you can then
you can sell to tons of people like you
have so much business you won't know
what to do with it but you have to
really hack that attention curve I see
Lady Lexi in the house welcome she's got
her hand up it's it's dark over there
how are we doing lady yeah that's true
it's dark out here it's uh almost a
quarter past eight in the evening so
that's correct
um yeah I do have a question
um so the last couple of weeks I have
been uh well the last couple of months
probably I haven't been doing much on
YouTube
um but here's the thing uh everybody
says uh that I need to make sure that if
I post a link on there say for instance
for
um doing a challenge that I need to do
an upsell as well
and that's where because I'm still
trying to figure out how to do it I am
completely stuck so I I'm
I I think I can do it but it would be
easier to just say okay I'm not going to
do an upsell get the challenge out there
and then keep going then not doing
anything at all anymore because that
link is not linked it should be because
there is no upsell
cool so there's two separate things here
the first is nothing should get in the
way of making content
oh great if you have a personal issue or
you know you end up traveling or there's
something happen cool but there's no
business reason like the fact that you
don't have an upsell should not be the
reason why you stopped making content
yeah but
content has to go up and listen it's
great and you already know uh you
probably thought I would say that anyway
but it's great you know it's like the
extra affirmation and like kicking the
butt to say okay ladies exactly
no more excuses let's make some content
right so thank you so so there's no
business reason why like you have to
start making content cool
now aside from that so if the model is
going to be content leads to a challenge
leads to an upsell right like is that
that's the model the upsell doesn't have
to be first up you don't need to have an
upsell
it helps with the business model but you
don't you don't need to do anything
except make content you need to make
content yeah
so that's the need but if you're going
you think about a value that you bring
to your audience so you have your
content you're making videos cool you
have a challenge and and what's what's
the point of your challenge or what's
the challenge called
how to speak uh it's the cleanup a
cleanup challenge so it's about
um looking at your old routines friends
whatever you're doing looking at once
the things you want to do see what
you've done in the in the in in the
recent past and then see how you can mix
it up to become a better routine uh but
it might be you know getting rid of
stuff friends and different goals
whatever cool so you have your cleanup
challenge awesome
that's valuable for people who are
watching your content you know it's
valuable for people who know you who've
seen some of the videos who might be on
your email list who might follow me on
Instagram like it's valuable for them to
say okay you know what I like lady Lexi
I want to clean up my life now it's
finally time she's gonna do this
challenge the challenge becomes a way to
do it together you know where they they
may not do it on their own but because
you're doing it and we get to do it as a
group I'm more likely to follow through
or at least I hope that I'm likely to
follow through because we get to do this
thing together right
so that's that's already incredible
value for people who who do decide to to
sign up and come out
if I think through the challenges that
we've done I mean sometimes
people get it they just get enough value
from The Challenge right away and like
that's enough you know and sometimes
that they did it they clean out their
their old habits they replaced them with
new ones they're grateful they got a
result
uh but some people they want they want
to do more you know some people
they they miss the vibe right like even
um on Tuesday we had we had people fly
into Toronto from the US and Dubai and
Canada and I did some coaching videos
with them and it was such a great vibe
that we made
that I was like when's the next one
yeah
people want the next one it's like when
oh I want to do that again like I want
that Vibe again I want the challenge
again right so hopefully in the
challenge you're creating you've helped
people inside the challenge
take a step that they were too afraid to
take themselves and they didn't feel
supported they didn't have the community
and they weren't doing it themselves but
now because of you and the group that
you created they are taking that next
step cool some people should then miss
it they're like oh man I wish I had this
every week or every month or I wish I
could talk to Lady Lexi more right
that's where the you know upsell I guess
would come from and say hey if you want
to work with me one-on-one or if you
want to if we want to do this as a
coaching program or group you know let
me know and here's the program that I
have and some people won't do it because
they don't
they don't want to do it they got enough
value from the The Challenge and like
that's it cool some people won't do it
because they don't have the budget to be
able to do it and they can't afford the
whatever it's going to be
um and some people will do it you know
and some people say yeah I'm actually
I'm ready to bet on myself I'm ready to
take the next step I'm I'm ready to take
some action build momentum and stop
staying stuck I'm ready
and so it doesn't have to be a fancy I
mean it could be as simple as a PayPal
link right it's like hey yeah for
anybody who's who found value in this
challenge like what's the thing that you
upsell what's the next step if you don't
even think about as an upsell like
what's the next step after a challenge
is it one-on-one work with you is it
group coaching what is it
preferably group coaching starting Oasis
set for
wheelching
group coaching okay so then the next
step becomes a one-on-one call with you
yeah
and that's a one-off call that's a once
a week call a once a month call
I would like it once a week for seven
weeks and then go into the group so once
a week for seven weeks is is the you
don't have to talk about the group Next
like don't make it too
the more options and it just scares
people so the next step is to hop on a
call if you like this you got value to
this and you want to you want to go
deeper with me the next step is
I do one-on-ones and it's it's seven
weeks where it's once a week and we got
on the phone or Zoom for half an hour an
hour how long is a call
uh some well probably an hour okay every
week for seven weeks for an hour yep and
and what does that cost to join
uh including the the group coaching for
say for the next year it would be
somewhere between two or three thousand
Okay so
if you guys found value in this
Challenge and you want you like this
energy and you want to continue
The Next Step would be to join me where
I do seven hours over seven weeks of
one-on-one calls with you and then we
form a group where we continue to help
each other for the next year and that's
2500 bucks and if you want to join
here's the link or message DM me on
Instagram and I'll send you the PayPal
or go like you can just put your PayPal
Link in the zoom chat and say PayPal
made 2500 bucks and you're in yeah that
part is covered so actually from the
previous challenge I I have someone and
we had to change the the amount of money
but I was like okay I'm just you know
coaching you uh weekly and then she'll
she'll be uh turned out for two uh group
coaching but for now it it gives me
value as well because
um the way I culture it gives me so many
ideas but the the doing this through
paypals having her the link you know uh
for the for the monthly payments that's
easy that that's doable I figured that
out it was just literally the upsell
that I was running into and if I can
keep it the same way and basically you
just can just change the link copy and
paste the whole thing change a few words
and then it's dumb okay so what do you
mean you're struggling with the upsell
is it the language or what to say or or
what no no no the the one click up shell
those things
because they say if you offer something
like a free challenge you also need to
give them the possibility to buy for
instance the book
or already subscribed to and because
that part is new to me uh so I've been
looking at it being going through kajabi
but there's a lot of work involved with
uh even in in kajabi and I found a
plugin I can use on WordPress which
looks doable but I've noticed it just
keeps me from from you know even the the
podcast I was going to do well we talked
about it last time was the the quality
which wasn't good so I've been looking
for new microphones and all that stuff
I've got it so I can start doing the
podcast but the whole
um just the blog post it literally got
stuck on but this it says go to the
cleanup challenge carcc.com cleanup
Challenge and I was like yeah but I need
that that under that one click upsell
because I didn't have it there I
literally got stuck for like three weeks
already because I wanted to start the
challenge this week and
yeah I mean the the upsell there or like
order bump rights order bump uh that
some people will will get it cool right
some people won't Whatever percent ten
percent twenty percent thirty percent
like it's not a hundred percent
especially off of a free challenge right
some people will get it okay
uh but think about how much you're
selling it for I mean
how much is your how much is your order
bump going to be for your book or
whatever
oh the book is not that much that's
probably about the seven dollars okay so
but and then I could of course this is
great because keeping things in
perspective like the reason why you
haven't you're supposed to launch a
challenge this weekend and the reason
why it didn't go up was because you're
missing out potentially on on a few
seven dollar sales
yeah
right and that's how to make you feel
bad we all get stuck in this kind of
this kind of stuff right like we all get
stuck on little things that we feel are
important and realize oh I didn't even
get my challenge up and like that's the
big thing so it's not that you is having
an order bump a good idea yeah is it
going to make a big difference no
and it definitely can't be the reason
why you're not making content and it
definitely can't be the reason why we're
not launching the challenges right so
it's it's uh it's like here's our
priority here's what has to get done and
then these are some nice to ads that we
can put on in the process and if you
don't figure it out in time you don't
figure it out in time and you figure it
out maybe for the next challenge right
yeah
um so that's it and and you know thank
you for being vulnerable and sharing and
you know coming on the spot because I
think a lot of people myself included
struggle with some of those things too
it's like I tell myself why am I this is
such a stupid thing why am I stuck on
this thing and then I'm not doing
something that I that I know I should be
doing and it's just a perspective shift
to come back to okay like a seven dollar
book that I'm gonna make a few sales off
of is not a good enough reason to say I
completely stopped making YouTube
content for three weeks and I didn't
launch a challenge that I was supposed
to right
um so anyway this is a nice little
perspective shift reminder to just get
it done and yes and maybe on the next
challenge you know the ebook is done and
maybe it's not but we have to make
content and launch our next challenge
okay well thank you so much I I just
needed this little push so thank you
we're here for you lady Lexi all right
thank you
what's going on guys
welcome welcome thank you thank you all
right so I was in here last week
um and uh Zen
um highly recommended that I hire you
know uh individuals to help me with my
journey and so forth and of course I'm
coming up with a budget for that
um my business is in real estate and I
have
um my passion is in the Performing Arts
I do a lot of Fitness I do so much of
like the on stage you give me a
microphone and I will dominate The Crowd
so that's my cycle
um so uh I you know I take the winnings
from competitions in Fitness and and
everything that I do in the shows so the
winning from the shows I invest in real
estate and then the real estate profits
I put back into the production of shows
okay and so I want to travel the world
and
um Zen recommended that I hire you know
um uh a team that will help me with uh
with all of that you know it's just a
matter of time and I have to say that I
have been so inspired by all the books
that I have read from you Evan and from
you know the just being on here is it
has generated so much energy for me to
be able to put forth
um all the effort needed so I don't know
what you can recommend as far as what
the next steps will be well what do you
what are you trying to build the most
right now when it comes to social media
when it comes to marketing and so forth
um YouTube is my platform for sure like
because I'm So Into like making videos
and
um just producing content with like that
caters to a platform like YouTube of
course I have everything else I
literally have everything else and I
have followed you on everything else
um
But ultimately like what do you want to
build and sell are you trying to sell
you as the fitness guy are you trying to
make you're going to educate people on
real estate like what do we want to
ultimately sell what's our business
model going to be
before worrying about some media
platforms like how are we going to make
money in our business
uh well
um so the the business center things is
real estate it gets really convoluted
because because of the uh Fitness and so
forth I am very like I'm a huge mental
health Advocate and I know that's a
major component within like the
homelessness like I I need to be able to
get people to
um you know uh kind of like reboot
so then they can be mentally in tune
with what they want in life provide them
the essentials so the businesses like
slash charity slash non-profit
and so then get them off the streets get
them into like
um
you know
um being uh living off of like
um the basics and transforming their
dreams into reality
and so if if we can if we can provide
homes for them
um if we can get them to realize how
important it is to to you know focus on
their their goals and their dreams then
you know uh the when it comes to giving
them those uh elements within the real
estate then you know hey if you're
you're a fitness competitor if you're
someone who is gonna uh wanna
you know uh send your message out then
by all means I'm all for that as well on
the fitness end of things
so I I mean I love the mission
it's great
it's great where a lot of people's
struggle is I've got this big mission
and you're not talking you're not trying
to solve some small problem you're like
you want to solve homelessness that's
not just one little tiny thing it's a
big deal
where people often struggle is okay I've
got this big mission
and I'm willing to work
but I don't know what to do to make it
work it's the truth and I'm out here
I'll tell you right now I bought four
acres up here in the northern far part
of Florida and
um I I I am literally putting myself in
the shoes of individuals that I want to
cater to so when it comes to like being
out here in the wilderness
um you know when people don't have money
to eat when you know all of this uh all
these different components that will
give me Insight on what it's like to be
like for example a homeless person on
the streets it will be
um so important for me to know in depth
um when it comes to what I can offer on
the real estate side of things and then
when it comes to just
maybe not everybody is like
um
uh on uh ready to be on the stage
they're not ready for an audience or
whatever but when it comes to telling
their stories or when it comes to just
them being physically mentally and
spiritually fit is something that I want
to be a part of cool I think what we
would need to figure out is the business
model that's going to help you go from
where you're at now to achieving your
big mission
because if you do it like you're doing
it it's great but it's small like the
way you're going now isn't going to
solve homelessness right so like if you
just take hey you're going to keep
competing and keep doing your thing and
take money put into real estate and over
time real estate keep growing and and
you're going to give one percent of what
you make from Real Estate to help
homeless people or whatever like you can
do that but it's like you're never going
to solve homelessness at that rate and
so it's not to this is where a lot of
people get stuck is like I I'm doing
this thing to serve the world on the
evenings and weekends because I don't
have a model to make it go
because if this was your full-time thing
and you had 400 people on your team
helping you now you can make a real dent
in the solving this problem as opposed
to this part-time thing and and that's
not to say what you're doing is not good
it's amazing like if everybody gave one
percent or whatever it is and spent
their evenings and weekends like
thinking about a cause that they cared
about what a much better world would all
be living in
the challenge is if you know you said I
don't know if it's charity or not for
profit
if you're relying on donations to make
something work you just basically become
a donation
organization and and all Charities are
like massively understaffed and
underfunded and are have a hard time
getting the the best people because
there's no real business model apart
from asking for help and so what I try
to encourage people not that that is
wrong if that's really the path you want
to go down but if you can figure out a
business model that that pays you that
allows you to do this full-time that
allows you to hire a team to then go off
and have a much bigger impact you're
just able to go off and have a much
bigger impact so what is something that
we can sell and you don't have to have
the answer right now
they can come back in weeks and you know
we'll be here and Dan will be here too
but okay what is something that we can
sell that then
we give up a portion back so if you if
you love mental health could you sell
mental health workshops will you have
people come to your facility in Florida
and they're coming and learning from you
and you're bringing in experts and
they're and they're people with people
with money have mental health problems
too
no it's true and they're coming um and
they're dropping four or five figures to
be there with you and
one person in the room was always gonna
be a homeless person and and 20 percent
of the profits go to support
homelessness in Florida or or whatever
it is but like we're building a business
model around it
so the skills that you've learned you're
teaching other people who have a budget
to pay you and then you're able to to
like every time I when I did my tour in
2019
uh we hit 23 cities 90 days and in every
stop we had five to ten percent of the
people who came in
who did not pay for their ticket
many of them were homeless when you
wouldn't tell like people think homeless
you have to be some bum and like super
smelly and like like that's actually not
like there's a lot of people you'd never
even know are homeless
so true and so we had some people who
would come in like I would always say
five to ten percent of the up to ten
percent of the audience that would be
free that I don't even want to know too
much about your story like I'm not here
to judge your story and like like you
can't afford it you can't get in we're
gonna give you this ticket and I hope
that it has an impact on your life right
but I'm making money off of the 90 which
helps me fund the trip and the airbnbs
and the hotels and the gas and the film
crew and everything else right it's like
you have a business that then allows you
if it was only going and doing workshops
for the homeless or for people who
couldn't afford it at all then I'm out
of business because I'm just out of my
pocket all the time we're trying to find
a sponsor find a donor all the time to
do it as opposed to hey I can make this
into a business and then I can hire a
bigger team which then allows me to help
even more and more people along the way
so the issues that the homeless people
are facing and the skill level up that
you want to give them is if it's around
something like mental health or Fitness
or educational real estate or how to be
an Entertainer perform or like whatever
the things are that you are deeply
connected to you can teach people those
things you can create programs in
coaching and centers helping people with
those things for people who have money
will pay you because they want to learn
those skills as well there's lots of
people with money who have mental health
issues there's lots of people with money
who want to learn real estate there's
lots of people with money who want to
get in better shape lots of people with
money who want to perform and learn how
to be great on stage like I don't know
what in there you want to teach maybe
it's all of them maybe it's two of those
things but in helping them you then also
bring people in who are homeless to be
able to be a part of that class and
again you're not seeing like ah that
that's the homeless person right like
they're just in the class
right there like everybody else uh but
then using ten percent five percent
twenty percent whatever depending on
your margins
then goes to support homelessness
in Florida as a starting point like if
you can start making that into a
business then now you have now like in
you and you come in here I'm trying to
figure out my budget to hire people well
the budget's all coming out of you right
so now the budget doesn't have to come
out of you and you dipping into your
savings to make it happen it's coming
out of clients who are paying and we
have a real business model now that we
can go off and turn this into a company
for good and that should go off and
accomplish our mission
I got a question so uh Evan I um I'm
very fortunate and grateful to say that
I've been invited to speak at a virtual
event on June 14th let's go I uh I
didn't uh I didn't expect to get the the
level of attention that they've given me
uh they there's it's a three-day event
34 speakers and they put me right after
the keynote presentation I'm I'm the
second speaker to to present great uh
and uh I'm working on the PowerPoint
presentation I'm practicing uh don't
have a lot of experience giving
presentations it's uh they say 30
minutes 15 minutes for questions uh
curious if you have any uh advice or
feedback because you're you're the
master at this kind of stuff so yeah
okay so a couple things so um is this is
fine as I'm the World's opening up and
I'm doing a bunch of presentations my
next one is in Vegas uh so maybe I'll
see Zan down there and it's in what two
weeks I think and I'm on just before
garyvee I think
uh and it's it's Sean's Sean Sean
Candles YouTube uh event happening in
Vegas so I've got
Sean was awesome yeah I think it's 25
minutes that I'm speaking for so a
couple things to think about uh one
audience interaction is always the best
you know like most people get up there
and just speak and speak and speak and
speak and it it's never as personal as
it could be so
as much as possible I love defaulting to
as much q a as possible but people need
to know what your they need to know what
to ask right so if I'm coming into room
and I've got 25 minutes to talk or
you've got half an hour to talk I would
love to set the stage with 10 minutes of
talking and presenting something so that
people know kind of who you are and what
you're talking about and then as much
time as q a as possible
uh that's my personal style I love it's
the most fun for me when you feel like
you're actually helping somebody I think
it's also the most value for the
audience too to see you helping somebody
out
um it's a lot more dangerous though it's
a lot more risky because you don't know
what's going to come at you and you hope
you're going to ask questions that you
don't know how to answer right if Tanya
says master class I don't know I don't
use a master class but you can you can
you can you can always say you don't
know there's nothing wrong with saying
hey I don't know right if you don't know
don't fake it and say well and like some
BS answer right
um so that's more personal preference I
used to do all scripted perfect
PowerPoint no time for Q a because I was
I was worried about disappointing the
audience and I would also talk really
fast
um which sometimes ESL uh people
couldn't understand
um and so it's like what's the if you
think about what's the main thing you
want people to get out of this like if
people they're gonna go to a three-day
event you're one speaker out of all of
the speakers that are there they're
going to leave with a notebook full of
ideas and most people are going to do
zero on it this is what happens at
events so
if you were the one guy that they
remembered
for one thing that they're going to take
action on what is that thing and make
the whole presentation about that thing
so that they can hopefully get into
action mode
the second thing though like if you want
to get more of this
be the person who brings the most value
to the event so when is your event June
something June 14th June 14th perfect uh
so when shot now I've known Sean for a
long time who organized the event but I
said hey Sean initially the only he was
giving me like 11 minutes or something
it's like cool Sean happy to come on do
whatever but if I'm coming down and I'm
going to be there for three days use me
if you want me to do breakdowns of
people's channels and you want to sell
it as a VIP bonus if you've got people
who've upgraded tickets and you want to
give them extra access I'm happy to do a
special session over lunch if anybody
cancels on the day of I'll come in and
talk on their session if they're hosting
any extra panels and you need an extra
member Count Me In if you want to do
some pre-promotion and talk about it I'm
happy to interview some of the people
who are also going to be speakers at the
event to talk about your thing to give
you content to go from like think about
the person organizing this event and how
you can be as valuable as possible to
them so they have a successful event as
opposed to just thinking about your
30-minute talk on this one day right
um because that way you like the next
time they're running the event who are
they going to call not Ghostbusters
they're calling Andrew Murdoch right
and you just get known as the person who
brings the most value because most
speakers now it's a virtual event so it
may not be the thing but most speakers
fly in fly out and they don't stick
around where if you're there and you're
asking people's questions and you're
helping and you're the most valuable
person there
um you're gonna get invited to a whole
bunch more stuff as well
um so
you know people who are putting on these
events are under a lot of stress and
pressure and a lot of moving Parts a lot
of chaos and people do cancel last
minute all the time on things and if
you're the guy who is always picking up
the slack
a lot of great things open up to you
um I don't know if you know Jamie do you
know Jamie carlima
no no she wrote a book called believe it
lady Lexi Tanya shaking her heads um
she wrote a book I believe it became it
was New York Times bestseller uh she's
gone on and done
events with Tony Robbins and Dean and
Brendan and you know part of our crew
and she she started a company called It
Cosmetics and sold it for a billion
three
in cash
it's a pretty awesome story like female
badass success story
um and at Brendan's event so Brendan
Bashar was hosting his event and one of
his speakers canceled last minute like
couldn't make it in whatever reason and
so he's asking who who can speak like
who else can come and speak and Jamie
was in the audience and one of the staff
members knew she was there and she said
have Jamie come up she's done some
on-camera stuff and has a great story
and so Jamie came on stage and that
became the birth of a whole
business for her now she's a speaker and
best-selling author although this other
stuff just because she was willing to
say yes so
um a lot of
balls drop on events like this and just
showing that you're willing to to be a
part of it
to you know again hope be on panels
replace somebody if they skip out host
an awards you know if they're giving out
Awards you're happy to host and give out
some of the awards uh bonuses any of the
VIPs who are upgrading part of that
bonus could be I don't know how many
people like it could be one-on-one with
you but that's too many a group session
bonus with you like how can you just
bring incredible value to the people
putting on the events and that opens up
if you if you want to do more speaking
and build more connection that opens up
just a huge world of opportunity
that's fantastic feedback thank you so
much for that and speaking to what you
just said just being willing to say yes
yeah I I didn't uh I didn't hear of this
event before never heard of this event
before they contacted me like a year ago
to uh guest speak on their podcast so I
I did the podcast and then never thought
about it ever again and then randomly
they reached out to me and said hey
Andrew uh we really loved having you on
the podcast we'd like you to apply to be
a speaker at our event submit an
abstract again submitted the abstract
but didn't give it a second thought and
now before I know it now they've they've
got me the second speaker in their their
events and I was like oh and just being
willing to say yes and just take where
the the universe is guiding me I guess
so well and just keep putting out
goodness and bringing value right I mean
today Thursday is our public facing day
for me so it's we started with Brian
Linux this morning and then it's just
all day podcasts and I'm on people's
shows and then this and then more
podcasts and when people ask me at the
end hey where can people find you like
it's always like where can people find
you what's one thing you can do for me
right and if you were if I was on your
show I'd say hey hey Andrew how many
episodes have you created of your show
and you say I don't know this episode
number 84. cool Andrew's done 84 of
these episodes guys if you love Andrew's
work and these episodes and I guess that
he brings on the best thing you can do
for me is go give him some love go to
the YouTube channel give him a thumbs up
give them a comment go to iTunes and
give him a review and give him five
stars because it's so much work to
create this show
that that little bit that you do makes a
means a huge difference to helping that
get up to more people right so I'll use
the time at the end to promote me to
promote you to promote the host and so
like you're the only one whoever does
that right yeah and so then you get you
get asked to be on other people's shows
you get asked to come back you get asked
to speak at events and then you get
asked to get paid to speak at events and
then you get book deals and right all of
this stuff starts to come because you're
always looking at how do I give
incredible value to the person who is
having me on right so you're not just
thinking about showing up for the 30
Minute Podcast or 30 minute interview
it's like how do I help this person grow
their business and grow their brand and
be a cattle it's more it's like for me
it's just good karma
like just help it's great
but it also becomes a a killer business
strategy because something will always
come back for you yeah Rising tide yeah
love that man thank you thank you all
right cool samit's got his hand up what
do we got to meet how are you Evan so
good man similar question to Andrew is
actually prior to the invitation
um I made an impact at a live event but
trying to get invited to speak at that
event and uh kind of get access
um in a larger way rather than being a
uh quote attendee where I was I was a
attending a mastermind
um feel that based on feedback had an
impact there now they're doing a a live
event for a larger community and trying
to get invited but wanted to do it in a
way there where I'm adding value to them
but not uh coming off as desperate or
yeah okay so two things one is in the in
the lead up to the event is that it's
ongoing it's not just hey I want to get
into this event that this is a
relationship you're trying to build
ongoing so always looking for new ways
to help them think of them I have a list
of people that I want to stay in touch
with and at least every 90 days I have
to do something to stay in touch with
them somehow right so put this person on
your list find a way to at least every
month think of some way to add value so
that when a next event comes up you're
automatically the person that people are
calling like I'm getting destroyed right
now with a number of invites to things
because over the past two years all I've
done has been helping people grow their
thing and now that events are coming
back and the World's opening up
everybody's like hey Evan can you come
speak at this Heaven Can you like
now it means a great problem to have but
it's because of two years of just
bringing incredible value to people so
think of it long term as well so every
30 days you're doing something to bring
value to them second thing is you reach
out like now you've got this event
coming up you reach out and thank you
when you say add value what does that
mean to you like what like that example
of what you shared uh when it comes to
speaking an event and standing out and
doing more than others like I wrote down
those like whatever it is in terms of a
value-op after that you're adding
additional when you say add value I feel
like it you know sometimes it's harder
to break that down of what is actually
meant to add value to you so that's
different for every person right so so
what values for me is different than
what's value for Sergio and Maria right
so uh I have a thing called be their
chief goal officer like whatever their
goal is becomes my goal so if Andrew is
going on to speak at this person's stage
what's their goal their goal is to have
a great event so Andrew can do more than
just give a kick-ass three-minute speech
he can help the entire event be better
and offer the sub in right that's
useless to somebody who's not hosting an
event
so the people who you're trying to
connect with what is value to them the
value that I can bring Brendan burchard
is different than the value that I can
bring Peter on right it's just
everybody's valuing different things so
that's your job is be their chief goal
officer and here's what's important
either you can do the work yourself or
you can make a connection to somebody
who can like a lot of times what they
need help with isn't something that you
can actually do but you can hustle to
find the person who can help them do
that thing and you're you're the guy who
made the connection happen so we often
default to say well I don't know how to
do that but you don't necessarily have
to know how to do that you can just try
to find the person who can help them do
that and a quick tell is look at their
Instagram bio look at their Twitter bio
what are they promoting what's in their
link that's what they care about the
most right now help them get more of
that thing
it's interesting very helpful thank you
um uh the other part is like okay well
that's how to build ongoing
relationships it's what do I do right
now because there's an event coming up
like when is that event coming up I
think it's a third week of June yeah all
these June events 11. uh you reach out
and say hey I'd love to come and speak
on x
and I I just did this with Alex who's
who helps me run trying to dance salsa
Alex is going there's an event in
Toronto right now for entrepreneurs uh
Archangel something happening
um and Alex's was gonna go as a guest
like you can't just go as a guest dude
that's not enough like you you need to
go and you should be on stage doing
stuff and like well but I don't have you
know people don't know me as a speaker I
don't have a story to share it's like
well and he's already got his lineup
book it's like okay cool well you're
what's your business he has dance
classes right he teaches people how to
do salsa bachata dancing like so what
does an event need event needs people to
Hype them up with dance you go to Tony
Robbins event before you get on you see
people dancing going crazy reach out to
him and say hey I'd love to Hype up the
crowd before you come on and teach them
some salsa dancing and get them going so
they're not in their seats
right and he said yes
so now two days in a row it was
yesterday and today this is very meta
it's like happening right now Alex wakes
up at like 5 30 in the morning gets
downtown Toronto to go to this event and
he's hyping up people and teaching them
how to dance before the next speaker
comes on this was not something that was
initially planned in his event
but it brought value to the person and
sure maybe maybe people come when they
sign up for classes but the point isn't
to sign up for dance classes we're not
selling anything there the point is to
build a relationship with the people who
are putting on the event so that now any
future event guess what they're going to
call Alex and have him be the hype man
at the front teaching people how to
dance
right that's that's super helpful and
one other thing I don't know if you've
ever enjoyed this but oftentimes it is
someone throwing the event might have
their business in one core area and if
you compete they're really trying to
build refer audiences but not a
competitor
does that make sense yeah but it's like
Chief gold officer like what are they
trying to what do they want to build
yeah and you help them you help them try
to build it if they're trying to build a
referral business help them get more
referrals if they're trying to build a
direct sales model help them get more
sales if you're trying to have a great
experience like and and sometimes you
have to guess
like everything I suggested for Andrew
is a guess
I don't know who I don't know the event
I don't know who who those people are I
haven't looked at their buy I haven't
looked at their website but haven't done
enough events
those things usually come up speakers
cancel there's bonus upgrades right like
there's opportunities like the thing
with Sean now turned into a 25 minute
thing that was supposed to be for 11
minutes and that's it before Gary right
now it's 25 minutes plus I'm gonna be uh
doing two other things with them there
plus we just did a live stream on this
channel two days ago talking about it
and so now I'm hyper involved in it just
because I want to be because I hate
going to an event and just sitting there
in the audience I like to be involved in
the thing
but you can take a guess at what they're
doing and the more that they're actually
sharing especially again like the hack
is to look at their their Instagram bio
Twitter bio see what they're promoting
but if you know that hey they're trying
to build a referral engine cool that's
like the greatest thing you can they can
tell you help them go build a referral
engine either you or make introduction
to them that can help I appreciate it
thank you Evan yeah cool and just one
last Quick thought on on all of this
because this all seems to be around like
networking Making Connections helping
people
um
Charisma on command I don't know if you
ever if you know their YouTube channel
but they made a they made a video on me
saying I was one of the greatest
networkers that he had met
like the guy who makes like the Charisma
Channel saying I'm like the greatest
networker that he's met it's crazy
because I don't think of myself as a
networker I hate networking events this
is the worst thing of all time for me
networking are you kidding me I don't
say hi to people I hate it but all I
basically was doing is he broke down
this video was I was just being people's
chief goal officer so one of the things
I did was when somebody somebody came
and talked to me and I always being an
introvert I'm curious so I listen and so
I asked what are you doing like why are
you here what are you what are you
trying to learn and one person said that
he was doing an interview series on
entrepreneurs I think it was one Sean
was there interviewing entrepreneurs he
was like hey I'm trying to get
interviews lined up from my YouTube
channel at the time it was uh it wasn't
his think channel was uh video
influencers I think was the name of the
channel
I'm trying to line up people for this
for my channel so cool so like chief
goal officer Sean's here because he
wants interviews for his channel right
so now anytime somebody's telling me
about their Channel I introduced him to
a bunch of people and other people just
based off knowing what they want it's
like hey do you know him oh hey do you
know him just people who came up to me
and started talking I learned about what
they wanted and connecting people
together all of a sudden I'm this genius
networker
like why are you kidding me I'm just
trying to help you guys right but I
didn't do anything I just introduced two
people together who didn't know each
other because I thought there might be
you know a common interest or need and
then you get you get people calling you
you get people wanting you to help them
with other things and be involved in
their product Services events Etc so you
know value is different to different
people be their chief goal officer
understand what they want and help them
get it I think it was Zig ziglars like
you can have anything you want if you
help other people get what they want so
it's like a Zane probably you know
saying what's the quote that's it you
gotta just like be the chief go officer
more than what you're hired to do the
advice for Andrew is like don't just go
and give a kick-ass tweet you could be
the most memorable speaker there awesome
that's great value and like plus how
else can we give value to these guys so
that their whole event is amazing not
just your individual speech right if you
can start thinking on that level just it
feels great you know but also amazing
things open up to you
what I wanted to do is I actually wanted
to learn more about Zan services so I'll
connect with him
um through Instagram but what I'm
looking to do is is try to get some more
insight on
um a new role that I'm going to be
playing
um at a at a startup so that's why I
thought maybe it might be helpful more
with yourself it's not to do with
blogging or anything it's part of an
accelerator program so a little bit of
that is is getting out of my comfort
level and and being exposed to startups
but further wanting to learn you know
kind of I've read the book and
kind of need a little bit more help in
terms of being able to structure my
career path
I'd say and and understand how I can be
of service to these institutions based
on the experience I've have with 20 plus
years in real estate and what I'm going
into is real estate technology startups
cool that's one question that's kind of
come up to my in my head so what are you
doing at the incubator
I'm assisting
um I'm actually co-running it oh cool
yeah it's with TMZ in our neighborhood
in Toronto oh you're in Toronto cool I
have uh out of uh Ryerson well I don't
even know what they call themselves now
but yeah Ryerson yeah it's not Ryerson
anymore yeah Metropolitan University or
University or something yeah and so is
that what you want to do you want to
like go co-found more I'd like to I'd
like to
um this is something new and you know
opportunities came about and something
I've been working on and it's taken
about two years to be able to find event
a VC to
um go back this and we're going to be
starting up uh in September I'm going to
be visiting the office later today
but that's something where I thought I
would be able to try to find out if I
can get some help from Zan or from you
just in terms of understanding again how
can I make an impact because a lot of
things you're seeing are are really
coming into into play here in terms of
being able to provide a service and
making sure that I have the opportunity
to grow and learn in that role
if that makes any sense
yeah
most incubators don't work
yeah and most companies at incubators
don't work and so if you're looking for
like next stage in life and what to do
after like that if you make it work
you'll have unlimited opportunities
to to join other incubators to start new
incubators the key is like make this one
thing work right for the entrepreneurs
coming in they struggle with
um the biggest thing to struggle with is
closing sales like they struggle with
getting their product depending on what
stage but it's usually it's an
incubators it's early stage it's early
stage yeah so like yeah it's one getting
getting their MVP getting their mineral
viable product like created and then
bring it in Revenue that the business is
shut down because they can't generate
sustainable cash flow right so right you
know if you're in real estate you
understand the cash and sales yeah and
try to utilize the network is what
you're saying yeah so so helping them
get to the point where they're at least
covering their costs so that they can
hang around long enough to blow up like
so many entrepreneurs are focused on I'm
gonna go change the world with my new
tech startup cool yeah let's get to the
point where you can stay sustainable
right what's what are those first sales
that we need to bring in and whether
that's you making introductions to
people
it's a big reason why people would join
an incubator yeah right you're gonna
introduce them to somebody that's going
to help yeah or if you're gonna just
stay on them and train them like helping
them with their pitch helping them with
their decks helping them on the phone
helping them do the follow-ups helping
them become sales people a lot of tech
startups suck at sales because they're
yeah that's what I'm finding Geeks you
know but they did enough to get into
into the incubator so they sold
themselves enough to get in there so
there's they've got something but it's
that combination of of the training to
do better sales
um even the accountability like if you
if you uh help them stay entrepreneurs
suck with accountability
right yeah so like they say they're
gonna do something and they don't do it
see Evan
um or are you saying that's me I don't
know no no I'm writing this down now I
haven't had his hand up um but
entrepreneurs suck with accountability
especially at the beginning when they
have no idea then this is their first
thing so
helping them with that like coming in
and setting what's what's our sales plan
guys
what's our what
what's our sales plan yeah right and
then helping them actually create one
and stick to it and making sure that
they're doing the thing that they said
they were going to do not just going
into the tech that they love geeking out
over and you helping make introductions
for them
allows them to have success which then
allows the incubator to have success
which then allows you to go wherever you
want to go afterwards
got it yeah it's helpful I appreciate
that
yeah
um there's the whole motivation side so
they keep bringing guest speakers and
all that kind of stuff but really it's
like get the get them to a sustainable
business and then get them to to going
off and changing the world
and and sales playing and uh
introductions so like for every business
identify their ideal clients and then
yeah your network and also friends of
friends who might be able to come in and
either buy from them or at least give
them honest feedback of of where they're
falling down like people will take a
meeting because they love supporting the
the university and they love supporting
incubators right you take the meeting if
you reach out and it may not become a
client but at least you get really good
feedback
and they may not know how to do that so
if you spent you know
half an hour a week with everybody
trying to help them make those
introductions
some of those will hit and you'll end up
really having a lot of success there and
then that's it you just have to make
that one work
and then you could be the incubator Guru
and go around the world doing it like
most of them fail so yeah so in this one
it's interesting because I've got we're
being backed up by a large pension fund
so that's going to be a bit of a live
case study in terms of the companies or
two or three companies that we choose
out of that incubator to work on lean on
them
okay lean on the investors and say hey
we've got a tech startup inside computer
peripherals or whatever we need we need
to get to these guys like every company
in their sales plan that comes through
you needs to make a list of their top 50
clients that they want to talk to and
you might know some of them already cool
and if not you lean on you talk to the
pension fund hey we need to talk to
whoever's in charge of tech at Royal
Bank
do you know anybody yeah okay got it
yeah I know where you come from is there
anything that you recommend I I read
any of your material or anything in
terms of because this is kind of really
pretty much what you are doing in terms
of helping the startups as well
um
I don't have a lot of good books to
wreck I don't really read a lot of books
I mean build to serve is great
required reading at the incubator
um but honestly it's just
you just have to be a resource for them
like help them get sales
like if they're coming in they probably
already have a mission then they're
probably working on their Tech but like
how do they commercialize this and if
you have big uh like the pension fund
that's involved in in your thing cool
they're investing into tons of companies
like the amount they're investing in you
is so small compared to their entire
portfolio the problem is most people are
not most of their portfolios are not
reaching out asking for help
and they have a deep network of people
so you reach out and say hey we need to
get to whoever runs Tech at Royal Bank
to get feedback on this can you help us
yeah I hear you so you're saying
leverage dmz's resources to our
advantage and network yeah like the
resources as a network yeah exactly
The Tech Guys need to know the like the
startup companies need to know how to
create their thing
create the product or service but right
the network to get it into the hands so
it's commercializable that needs to be
pulling on DMZ pulling on all the
investors and that could be you to help
be the liaison for that
and maybe they say no cool but most
people aren't even asking yeah yeah
you're right I appreciate it yeah
cool thank you you got it
um
there you go
but you know what this is very meta this
is very meta like what Zen just did here
it you were acting like most of the
companies in your incubator act yep
you're right hidden camera off yeah not
asking questions but needing help or
like that's everybody who's coming
through your company
they don't want to turn the camera on
and ask for help and and talk about
their business because they'd rather
just stay tinker and attack and what Zen
said like hey come on and ask this
question
and hopefully you get no it I could have
not picked you I could have said no
screw this guy without his camera on I
could have like not given you good
advice but at least you took the shot
right yeah no I agree I need to be the
Zen for everybody who comes in and help
open up even if like Zan didn't have the
answer to this question he would have
answered some other way but the way he
didn't have the answer but he
facilitated the connection that's all
you need to do you may not have the
answer to who runs Tech at Royal Bank
but you can facilitate the connection
with these people so that they can start
to grow got it it's awesome thank you
thanks man there you go thank you Zan
that's what it's all about if you want
to get a copy of build to serve and join
us live for our next training with me to
ask your questions you can go get the
book right there next to me right there
I'll see you there I'll see you to get
the book it's a good one much love